even though is from Switzerland it's  very hard for a Frenchman to get off the  shadow of jean-luc godard is innovative  and groundbreaking achievement turned an  industry on its ear and started  cinematic result revolution called  Landon valve I am Johnny Gaddar has been  called the most original film maker of  the 20th century it's not surprising his  work is like no other audacious  controversial challenging transformative  and exhilarating his influence on  generations of film makers is impossible  to calculate and he has left movie  lovers around the world absolutely  breathless as you know the master  unfortunately can be with us here  tonight but if he were he would light up  the room because has everyone who knows  him can tell you Gaddafi is especially  famous for his glowing and sunny  personality  you